donc si c'était à refaire votre vie
qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez pas pareil
mon Seigneur bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde a parlé
alors vous êtes né le 11 septembre 1935
à Saint-Dizier en Champagne père
négociant 20 pratiquant mais sans plus
merci croyante mais pas grenouille de
bénitier
c'est vers 6 ans que vous découvrez
votre vocation en servant la messe à la
chapelle du couvent des sœurs de
l'adoration à Saint-Dizier vous dites
j'aimais beaucoup la liturgie on
m'appelait l'enfant du couvent il se
trouve que ce monastère se trouvait à
200 mètres de la maison et il y avait
une beauté de des lieux
il y avait le sens à comment exposé il y
avait les bougies les fleurs les champs
latins des sœurs il y avait une ambiance
je me voyais bien comme prêtre alors
vous attendez le bac pour vous inscrire
au séminaire mais votre vrai séminaire
en fait ce sera l'Algérie en 1957 à
l'âge de 22 ans vous partez faire votre
service militaire en Algérie et de cette
expérience vous tirez deux enseignements
d'abord la non-violence et ensuite un
sentiment de fraternité envers les
musulmans et d'amitié envers les
Algériens au fond je n'étais pas préparé
à la guerre d'Algérie vous savez
j'arrivais là-bas entraînant les pieds
parce qu'il fallait y aller et
premièrement je comprenais pas
finalement pourquoi on était là et que
l'Algérie française ça me paraissait
difficile quand il y avait une embuscade
c'était les représailles dans les
villages et tout et tout et je me disais
mais ça peut pas s'arrêter qu'est-ce qui
peut s'arrêter j'avais pas de solution
alors je ne portais pas les armes
j'étais
officier dans ce qu'on appelait les
affaires algériennes de pacification
donc j'étais avec des Algériens
et peu à peu je me suis ouvert à la
non-violence c'est violentement
lentement en 1960 vous êtes envoyé à
Rome pour poursuivre des études de
théologie et le 18 mars 1961 vous êtes
ordonné prêtre
en mai 68 vous êtes émerveillé par la
liberté de parole des étudiants vous
dites les prêtres des diocèses osés
enfin parler de plein pied à leur évêque
là aussi c'est un tournant oui je crois
qu'ils étaient délivrés de la peur
alors il se mettait à parler et j'étais
celui à qui devais écrire alors je
recevais un courrier très abondant des
prêtres mais je n'en venais pas et alors
le pauvre évêque vraiment qu'est-ce qui
recevait il y avait un défoulement vous
voyez un défoulement alors l'évêque me
disait c'est bon c'est bien je dis c'est
pas très bon pour vous
alors vous n'avez pas oublié tout ça
lorsque le 20 juin 1982 vous êtes nommé
évêque d'Évreux la preuve un an plus
tard vous apportez un soutien public un
jeune objecteur de conscience poursuivi
par le tribunal d'Évreux j'ai un peu
hésité quand même il était venu me
trouver ce jeune
vétérinaire et donc je vais au tribunal
à Évreux il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
de la région qui le soutenaient et puis
alors il y avait un avocat de Paris
de felis qui a un moment donné dans sa
paire horizon lié monsieur le Président
au milieu de ces jeunes il y a le nouvel
évêque d'Évreux qui est là pour les
soutenir etc ça fait le plus mauvais
effet du tribunal
dans l'armée et la magistrature et le
pauvre jeune que je voulais aider il a
eu la plus lourde peine qu'on a mis en
France pour lui mais il a fait appel à
Rouen il était relax en 1983 vous faites
partie des 10 évêques qui votent contre
la dissuasion nucléaire oui je l'ai dit
je l'ai dit et par rapport aux essais
nucléaires je suis parti à Moreau
en 84 vous refusez de vous associer à la
grande manif pour l'enseignement libre
pourquoi il y avait un collège à Évreux
et je trouvais que c'était le collège un
peu des bonnes familles un peu bourgeois
et je trouvais que il devait s'ouvrir à
des gens pots qui pouvaient pas payer
etc et donc que l'enseignement public
n'était pas simplement les seuls à
accueillir les plus pauvres
en 85 vous soutenez le soulèvement des
Palestiniens dans les territoires
occupés vous rencontrez Yasser Arafat à
Tunis c'était très gonflé ça à l'époque
c'est vrai parce qu'on pensait que
Arafat s'est un terroriste qui avait
cette étiquette allait vous rencontrez
un terroriste etc et je me rappelle que
quand Jean-Paul II a accueilli Arafat
alors les gens là n'en venaient pas elle
dit voyez même le pape mais vous avez
été la première
en 88 vous prononcez en faveur de
l'ordination des hommes mariés il y a un
droit de humain de se marier il faut
laisser les gens libres de se marier de
ne pas se marier de vivre en couple
comme ils veulent ça c'est une décision
personnelle la liberté de l'individu et
c'est vrai pour les prêtres et donc je
souhaitais que il y ait des prêtres
mariés ou pas mais c'est leur liberté la
même année vous vous déclarez prêt à
donner la bénédiction aux homosexuels je
pense que les homosexuels aussi ont
droit au bonheur c'est une bonne
question de tolérance d'accueil une
question de droit et je trouve que si la
société avance dans ce droit faut aussi
que l'Église puisse accueillir des
homosexuels qui le désirent
maintenant c'est le cas oui ça avançait
finalement je suis heureux de voir que
bien des sociétés bien des mentalités
ont évolué mais c'est pas encore terminé
il y a des gens qui sont très
réfractaires alors en 1989 dans le
mensuel lui vous affirmez que l'acte
sexuel est quelque chose de grand et de
beau le plaisir fait partie de nous et
de la vie dites-vous donc je crois que
ce qui a fait bondir un peu tout le
monde c'est le fait que j'ai pu écrire
dans lui voyez peu importe ce que
j'avais pu écrire mais le lieu où ça
s'était manifesté et je me rappelle que
des gens n'osaient pas les acheter lui
dans les Kios c'était il demandait à
quelqu'un d'autre d'aller leur prendre
de leur acheter mais c'est vrai j'ai
donné cette interview j'ai dit ce que je
pensais alors en 1991 vous opposez à la
guerre du Golf
avec le livre lettre ouverte à ceux qui
prêchent la guerre et la font faire aux
autres et dans la foulée vous condamnez
le blocus contre l'Irak
alors le titre me plaît le titre me
plaît et depuis l'Algérie je suis devenu
un anti-guerre je crois que la guerre
est toujours un échec et ça ne résout
rien il n'y a pas de bonne guerre c'est
pas facile de sortir de la guerre
quand le cardinal de Courtrai dit mieux
vaut la guerre que le déshonneur vous
répondez mieux vaut le déshonneur que la
guerre exactement alors il était furieux
après moi je dis écoute tu aurais pas
dit ça ça aurait été mieux mais il m'a
demandé on s'est rencontré à propos de
ça vous voyez c'était difficile mais vos
rapports avec la hiérarchie catholique a
toujours été bien des difficultés c'est
vrai
en 1994 Vietnam des fondateurs de
l'association droit devant qui vient en
aide aux immigrés
et l'un de vos livres coup de gueule
contre l'exclusion vous voulez foudres
du ministre de l'Intérieur de l'époque
Charles Pasqua après celle de la
hiérarchie catholique c'est-à-dire que
là vous commencez à vous mettre ado non
seulement les biens pensant à les
hiérarchie catholique mais aussi le
pouvoir politique c'est vrai alors j'ai
envoyé le livre à Charles Pasqua je suis
même dédicacé en disant à Charles Pasqua
me dit l'intérieur dont je parle si
souvent dans ses pages il m'a pas
répondu mais il était furieux de ce
livre et donc il a écrit au Président de
la Conférence épiscopale pour dire je
fais un procès à l'évêque d'Évreux alors
le président a écrit à Charles Pasqua me
désavouan en disant un évêque n'a pas à
écrire comme ça c'est pas son rôle etc
ça a calmé Charles Pasqua alors à
l'époque quand on vous interroge vous
dites ce n'est pas l'évêque d'Évreux qui
révolutionnaire ce sont les évangiles et
je crois que cette phrase résume votre
vie je trouve que l'Évangile est
subversif
par rapport aux autorités civiles
religieuses par rapport à
des valeurs de la société par rapport à
aux pauvres c'est vraiment c'est un
Jésus est venu amener le feu sur la
terre le feu à la société le feu à la
religion le feu à tout ce qui
déshumanise l'homme et son message a été
perverti par l'Église oui souvent il est
il est travesti il est il est camouflé
enterré si bien que l'Évangile c'est un
peu inodore sans saveur il faut garder
sa force et c'est à nous de remettre ce
ferment dans la société vous savez
d'ailleurs été la démarche des
protestants à l'époque c'est vrai c'est
vrai là vous acceptez l'invitation de
Christine Bravo pour l'émission froufrou
c'est vrai diffuser le samedi à 19h sur
Antenne 2 voilà c'est les britté là vous
êtes vraiment l'évêque qui fait froufrou
quels ont été les réactions de votre
entourage à cette notoriété
et bien dans l'entourage c'était très
réservé l'émission comme frou-frou le
titre déjà vraiment même si ils n'ont
pas vu l'émission ils étaient déjà
scandalisés et puis
il disait toujours mais Gaillot il est
là on l'attend pas mais qu'est-ce qu'il
va faire etc il n'a rien à faire là il
est avec une enquête dans sa cathédrale
il est pas là souvent etc enfin il y a
eu beaucoup de difficultés oui fou fou
est une émission qui m'a attiré des
ennuis bon rapport avec les médias
étaient excellents à l'époque quand vous
étiez le chouchou des médias oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai
et bien j'ai gagné quand même pas mal
d'argent que je reversais à
l'association diocésaine et même j'ai
perdu de l'argent parce que moi qui n'y
connais pas grand chose je devais payer
des impôts non seulement je donnais ce
que je touchais qu'il fallait que je
paye des impôts bon enfin c'est comme ça
vous avez fait votre pauvreté en
devenant de toute façon et alors c'était
difficile dans votre vie Monseigneur de
rester chaste j'aurais aimé fondé une
famille oui avoir des enfants ça c'est
sûr mais bon je voulais suivre Jésus
l'Évangile comme prêtre
quand on a 25 ans on se lance puis on y
va et quand j'étais jeune le problème
c'était l'Algérie voyons d'abord
l'Algérie il faut que j'en revienne
c'est pas sûr qu'on en revienne donc on
verra après mais même si on fait le
choix du célibat c'est pas pour ça que
c'est facile vous voyez c'est bon
heureusement j'ai toujours été
bien entouré dans des communautés
équipe et puis
il y a eu des femmes merveilleuses
vraiment des gens des couples j'ai eu de
la chance mais vous pensez quand même
que c'est une souffrance
inutile qui est infligée au prêtre je
pense encore une fois qu'il faut laisser
la liberté vous voyez que des gens
veulent être célibataire Pourquoi pas et
il faut les respecter mais qu'on laisse
cette liberté au prêtre c'est un droit
alors le meilleur moment de tout cette
époque ça a été quoi c'était le fait de
rencontrer d'avoir voyez je fais un
livre il y a beaucoup d'échos qui
reviennent les gens dirigent j'ai lu ça
ça m'a permis de comprendre c'était je
pensais pas au départ qu'un livre
pouvait être ou bien une émission et
bien encore aujourd'hui voyez il y a des
gens qui disent je vous ai vu chez
Christine Bravo là j'ai vu qu'un enfant
un évêque était un homme bien sûr et
puis votre message il faut le porter
dans des endroits inattendus si c'est
pour faire ça le dimanche matin dans le
jour du Seigneur c'est moins efficace
exactement donc j'étais dans des
émissions
le coup pret tombe le vendredi 13
janvier à midi vous ne serez plus évêque
d'Évreux c'est arrivé très rarement
c'est arrivé après la guerre je crois
que de Gaulle à virer deux évêques qui
avaient été collaborationniste oui
d'accord mais il y a pas eu d'autres
exemples oui mais j'ai quand même été
surpris cette décision brutale on me
demande de venir à Rome bon je viens
qu'est-ce qui se passe et puis on me
signifie que demain à midi je serai plus
avec des vrais alors en sortant je le
dis mais ce que j'ai bien compris parce
que j'étais le seul témoin j'étais comme
ça et ben j'ai repris le train de nuit
je suis venu en train je suis reparti
comme quand j'étais étudiant et puis
avant de m'endormir dans le train je dis
faut quand même que je fasse un
communiqué pour les médias et puis un
communiqué pour le diocèse d'Évreux
alors je fais mon petit communiqué et
puis je m'endors alors vous serez à
partir de là nommée évêque de Partenia
en Partenia ce nez chez algérien disparu
le 5ème siècle donc ça veut dire évêque
de rien en fait au départ mais
paradoxalement
Partenia le site internet Partenia
devient le symbole de de ceux que
l'église ou la société ont rejeté qu'on
le sentiment de ne plus exister
écoutez oui il y a des amis qui m'ont
dit tu peux plus écrire dans un bulletin
diocésain tu as un instrument
merveilleux internet il faut t'y mettre
alors je vais suis mis et puis très vite
il y avait tellement de courrier de
questions que on a fait ça en 7 langues
il y avait une moyenne de 800 000
personnes parlent oui c'est-à-dire que
ce diocèse virtuel marche beaucoup mieux
que les vrais diocèses chaque mois on
voyait qu'il y avait des gens du Brésil
de Russie de Chine il y avait toujours
deux du Vatican
ces espions à mon avis alors en quittant
les déchets d'Évreux vous logez une
année dans le squat rue du Dragon à
Paris au milieu des familles de
sans-papiers et là vous devenez un peu
l'évêque des pauvres quoi l'évêque SDF
et donc j'ai fait cette transition de
passer quand même les déchets qui
étaient une maison bourgeois à une pièce
vraiment il y avait pas de chauffage il
y avait pas d'eau enfin bon mais ça m'a
pas coûté il y avait une ambiance dans
les familles de c'était très beau il y a
beaucoup de monde qui passaient
il y avait des gens qui me protégeaient
à l'entrée vous savez il y a Gaillot il
est parti à Rome alors ça c'était le mot
les gens dire ah bon alors voilà
évidemment à ce moment-là les médias
vous appellent moins oui je suis pu en
responsabilité donc c'est normal je
trouve que bon c'est une autre époque et
c'est pour moi une autre vie un autre
peuple vous êtes nostalgique de l'époque
de froufrou non je crois que vraiment je
vis autre chose et puis le passé c'est
le passé j'en y reviens pas je
marche en avant en innovant et avec des
gens que j'avais pas prévu de rencontrer
et je fais ma vie en marchant vous avez
de la rancune par exemple contre Charles
Pasqua parce que si vous avez été évincé
c'est aussi à cause du pouvoir politique
français peut coûter non non je peux
dire que je veux pas de rancune dans le
coeur et que je serais presque tenté de
les remercier parce que ils m'ont permis
d'aller plus loin
quand on avec un diocèse comme Évreux
c'est pas facile vous savez d'aller vers
ceux qui ne sont pas dans l'église et
souvent on me demandait le samedi
après-midi le dimanche à Paris par le
dalle etc j'y pense pas je peux pas je
peux pas maintenant j'ai cette liberté
de je suis libéré de tout ce qui est
institutionnel dans l'église et merci à
donc si c'était à refaire votre vie
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je crois que j'ai perdu beaucoup
de temps voyez par exemple pour venir
non violent m'a fallu du temps
anti-guerre il m'a fallu du temps j'ai
je suis lent voyez et je me positionne
bon mais il faut que ça mûrisse et il
faudrait que ça mûrisse plus vite alors
lorsque vous allez mourir plus tard
possible j'espère mon seigneur qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on écrit sur votre
tombe mais écoutez il y aura rien parce
qu'il y aura pas de tombes avant je vais
donner mon corps à la science un
institut à Paris là pour les étudiants
en chirurgie donc on prendra mon corps
et puis on m'insignera on mettra dans
dans le coin là
cimetière parisien vous savez voilà
comme ça donc il y aura rien il y aura
pas de temps de Gaillon non merci
Monseigneur c'est très heureux de
rallumer la lumière merci beaucoup merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu